here in Brazil I've learned that people
really do enjoy hugging have you in have
you guys found that hugging I love my
team what feelings right now
yeah I really have a lot to talk about
with this movie um I have to start with
YouTube because you were involved in the
opening car chase that that Chase is
I've seen a lot of movies I've never
seen a chase like this in Italy in my
life like it's I don't even know what it
cost to make this that chase yeah it's
seven hundred million dollars and that
just that that was just one of his
planes he had to sell me that yeah yeah
no but it's it's crazy what the f was it
like filming this thing in Italy cuz I
don't think they've ever allowed that
today will never allow it again pretty
nuts I need you know I don't think they
must have left some details out because
it was it you have a high-speed chase
this dayglo green Alfa Romeo around a
hundred miles an hour on streets that
are not built for this
like streets that have about an inch on
either side of the car two beautiful
historic stone buildings and that car
was just precision drivers obviously
somehow someway nothing was damaged and
the entire shoot well I I don't know how
that's possible
we were yes we were all emotionally
damaged nothing natural will be
reenacting this car with therapists for
decades but but yeah somehow they did it
and and I don't I think they were very
happy to see us leave Lawrence was like
bye you're by the West after watching it
I think that's true yeah yeah that was a
month of shooting just now seen just
once yeah I'm telling you I watched the
movie with my jaw open because I've seen
a lot of car chases I've never seen
anything like that
its iconic man like it's like in terms
of like opening car chases yeah right
after
yep yes but so now I want to switch to
actually Michael Bay I've seen him work
in person I can honestly say there's no
one like him on any set I've ever been
on we can't really ours many schemes
yeah um I all I'll say is I got in the
course of one day of watching I saw him
have a full Bay out like at least twice
and then you know pull it like I just
saw a lot of stuff in one day in one day
so there dog days so you actually had 75
I'm not gonna do that math between three
at three and a half years I am curious
though what um there's really no one
like him what was it like working with
him if you could each share a story
maybe something fun maybe something
surprising hmm he's I'll start with
surprising surprising is that Michael
Bay has a kind of ability for visuals
that no other person has and I think
that that everyone knows that but what I
didn't know going in is that he's
shooting all of it I mean he's got his
little green camera and he's jamming it
into places and he's just shooting stuff
I mean he's in there he sort of sees it
all on his head and everyone else is in
an absolute fog because which is the
chaos aspect of it nobody knows what
they're doing you show up to set nobody
even knows where Michael is half the
time like you know suddenly you're just
like it's just suddenly turns into this
sprint of go go go go go and nobody
really knows what's happening Michael
just starts putting people places and it
was a weird sort of it's a surrender you
just had to surrender to it the first
days when you don't know about that and
you just want to say your life yeah yeah
no because I have advantage good for
they know okay if you ever did any flips
it then he flips it you'd be like Corey
now talk for five no when you're like
about what Michael I don't know about
your character life yeah it's crazy man
it's it's absolutely insane no one
defend oh yeah of course we yeah
nobody's think it's like a crazy it's
like a crazy energy and you and you wait
for like hours and then suddenly you
like in that crazy said mm-hmm doing
crazy things and we loved each other I
was always just fell in love like that
were forged in fire this cast but I
really do feel like each and every one
of us would take a bullet for each other
yeah we don't blow away maybe I got like
a hard orange or like a like a sandbag
getting warmer a light breeze for sure
alight dreams but I was like halfway
through the shoot I remember I was like
looking at this gasps I was like wow
these aren't just cast mates these are
not just friends these are my future
pallbearers Carrie and Myka fed in a
casket across the wherever and bury me
in the Canadian Pacific yeah